Нехай їхні партійні кольори і схожі на прапор Ямайки,
але програмні цілі консерваторів, зелених та вільних демократів
у Німеччині все ще не пасують одна до одної.
Упродовж місяця представники цих партій лише зондували,
чи розпочинати їм коаліційні переговори.
За цей час злагоди вдалося досягти лише в кількох пунктах:
Передусім щодо майбутньої зовнішньої політики Німеччини.
Також всі погоджуються з тим, що потрібно збільшити інвестиції
будівництво нового житла за доступними цінами.
Існує консенсус і щодо створення достатньої кількості місць
у групах подовженого дня у початковій школі - нині вони в дефіциті,
також щодо більшої фінансової підтримки родин.
Потенційні коаліціонери також хочуть запровадити маркування продуктів
за критерієм дбайливого поводження з тваринами.
Але докорінних змін аграрної політики –
як того вимагають зелені – не очікується.
Час спливає, а з багатьох важливих питань
позиції сторін все ще дуже далекі:
Наприклад, щодо захисту клімату:
зелені хочуть закриття вугільних електростанцій.
Решта проти – хоча це й суперечить кліматичним цілям,
проголошеним особисто канцлеркою Анґелою Меркель.
Транспортна політика – ще одна дискусійна тема.
Заборону двигунів внутрішнього згоряння з мовчазної згоди зелених
зняли з порядку денного.
Але до подальших поступок зелені не готові.
Утім, найбільший камінь спотикання на шляху до коаліції -
міграційне питання. Якщо зелені
хочуть ще більше лібералізувати це питання,
то ХСС - сестринська партія ХДС Анґели Меркель -
авпаки прагне, щоб дотеперішній курс став більш суворим.
Пошук компромісу ускладнюється тим,
що менші партії бояться розчарувати своїх виборців
надмірним прогинанням під партію Меркель.
Якщо німецькі консерватори, зелені та ліберали не домовляться,
залишається два сценарії - так звана велика коаліція
християнських демократів з соціал-демократами
або - нові вибори.